i never thought that i was a person who
would start a company i just cared a lot
about this problem
and i studied it for a while and worked
on it as a volunteer and eventually
found a narrow slice of the problem that
i thought
me and and people with similar skill
sets to me
and a team that i could build could
solve so
my advice would be that the people who
start companies are just like you and
you should do it
i'm clementine jacoby i am the executive
director of recidivis
which is a non-profit technical company
that works directly with state
governments to help them
quickly and safely and equitably reduce
incarceration i grew up with family
members who
went into our prison system really young
and are still there today
but i think it wasn't until college that
i actually started studying the problem
and started to understand the real
contours of it and to see the extent to
which the united states was an outlier
so
i think for me it was a combination of
you know a personal
experience with the system but then also
realizing that we probably couldn't
solve a problem this big one person at a
time
and that it was going to take sort of
scalable and systemic solutions that
came in part from the inside
as well as the things we're doing from
the outside
i think the american dream means that
the circumstances you're born into
don't dictate your life's outcomes and
where
the color of your skin doesn't dictate
your outcomes
the data is pretty clear that that dream
is
on life support at best at the moment
there's lots of reasons to have
hope we've reduced incarceration as a
system
as a country more in the last six months
than in the last
decade racial disparities have been
going down slowly but surely for the
last 15 years
so it's an incredibly overwhelming
problem
to be working on but also one that i
think shows a lot of signs of progress
and there's lots of reason to think that
2020 in the next few years are going to
bring even more progress
you